The number 36 is three
times as large as 12.
Write this comparison as
a multiplication equation.
So they're saying that the
number 36, we'll type 36,
is equal to 3 times 12.
And I will use this
little star thing.
Let's see, if I were
to put an x there,
would that have worked as well?
No, they would have
viewed that as 3x.
So to get this little star
thing, which is normally
when you're typing on a computer
how you show multiplication,
to get that you have to
press Shift and the number 8.
And it also sometimes shows
up on a numeric keypad.
But by doing that, I was
able to show multiplication.
So this could be read
as 36 is equal to 3
times 12, or 36 is 3
times as large as 12.
Let's check our answer.
Got it right.
Let's do a couple more of these.
We can compare the numbers
4 and 20 using addition
by saying that 20
is 16 more than 4.
Fair enough.
That's right.
We could also compare 4 and
20 using multiplication.
Fill in the blank correctly
to compare the numbers
4 and 20 using multiplication.
So they're saying 20 is
blank times as large as four.
Well, we know that 4 times 5
is 20, or that 5 times 4 is 20.
So 20 is 5 times as large as 4.
If I do 4 five times,
I'll get to 20.
So let me check my answer.
There you go.
Let's do one more.
The number 6 is three
times as large as 2.
Write this comparison as
a multiplication equation.
So once again, we could
write that 6 is equal to 2,
and then I press
Shift and the number 8
to get that times
symbol, that little
asterisk
snowflake-looking thing.
2 times 3.
So I could write
it like that, or I
could write 2 times
3 is equal to 6.
Either of those would be
completely valid things to say.
So here I'm saying 6
is-- well, actually,
I'd like to say it this way.
I'd like to say three
times as large as 2.
I think that's a
little bit more fun.
So this is exactly 6 is
3 times as large as 2.
And we're done.